[Music]
yes bro that's just how it goes down is
the best thing I've ever done in my
[Music]
life hey what's going on everybody for
first week Feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Sterling K
Brown he's an Emmy sag and Golden Globe
award-winning actor you know from
beloved TV and film projects Like This
Is Us Black Panther and many more he's
also been very busy this year with a
pair of acclaimed films including
biosphere and coming this December the
core Jefferson directed satirical drama
that's riveted Festival season it's
called American fiction on the topic
congrats on the Excellence and acting
award that you recently received at the
Denver film festival and Sterling K
Brown at long last welcome to the show
oh [__] I'm excited sorry I got a little
carried away it's been a long time
coming I'm looking forward to this happy
to be sitting across from youan uh I
like chicken I like hot stuff I've never
gone this hot before so it's going to be
a new experience for your boy I know
there's going to be a little bit of
sweat but I've already finished in my
head like I'm so I'm we're just working
from the from the end and we're going to
see how we finish this process well the
hard part's over you ready get started
let's do it brother come
on
okay gotcha so we start right here this
is
[Music]
how yeah
good I like that baby steps you wait to
the
water
[Music]
okay so the buzz around American fiction
has been something to behold from
winning the People's Choice Award at
Tiff to variety calling it so funny it
just might be this year's Oscar Best
Picture Winner I'm curious what's your
reaction to the reaction you know it's
Unique to see this level of critical and
audience Acclaim especially surrounding
a firsttime
director did not anticipate it at all I
knew when I read it that it was a good
script with a great story and it sort of
pokes fun at the Hollywood Machine in
terms of what kind of stories Hollywood
wants to see black people in and it
tends to be sort of trauma porn and this
is not that and the movie sort of
skewers the industry just a little bit
by with the satire while also giving
them a family drama in the midst of it I
think it's pretty cool I think it's
something that me as someone who grew up
in the BBS in St Louis Missouri has been
eager to see like my life told in a way
that doesn't feel sensationalized or
utilized to evoke guilt it's just a
story it feels good I'm happy about
[Music]
it this that angry girl Peppa come on
angry goat what you got for
me oh that's tasty we like that one hey
y'all got some tasty food up your street
man I like this you ain't give me enough
time to eat all my chicken let's
go I'll take my foot off the gas over
you just dig in this all good you edited
however you got to I'm just
eating what role if any did your
performance in Gods spell as a freshman
at the Country Day School outside of St
Louis what role if any did that play in
building your confidence as a young
actor you got to do this every every
interview you pull out some [__] nobody
ever asks and it's always great it's all
of you I I see the people behind the
screen it was huge um I was just a
member of The Ensemble but it was that
high that you experience from sort of
being on stage I felt it as a football
player as a basketball player but this
way I was feeling it without getting hit
at the same time which was pretty cool
it was also like the first thing that I
did and my mom loved it and because my
mom is the strong Christian soldier that
she is I think she was supportive of
this artistic Journey from the beginning
if it had been a more risque show she
may have been a bit more apprehensive so
I think the universe brought the right
show into my life at the right time for
my family to stand behind me as I moved
into this sort of artistic world of Del
delineating The Human Condition
whatever okay see I see what you do
these first three are [__] delicious
right like they're really really good
feel you about to blow my booty hole out
in second though so that's all I got
what's your next question s how about
this one which is a bigger challenge for
an actor right shooting a scene where
you're holding back tear or shooting a
scene where you're actually shedding
them holding back holding back for me um
I hydrate a lot drink a lot of water I
sweat a lot so showing the Restraint of
someone who doesn't want to let
something out by seeing it just under
the surface is is a harder thing like uh
have you ever seen what's the movie with
um Robert Downey Jr directed by Ben
Stiller Tropic Thunder yeah yeah classic
all right you never want to go
full you understand what I'm saying I
follow I follow you follow follow you if
you can go right up to but not full I
think the audience feels it even more
because they're like oh this poor guy
can't let it all out
right
Bara it's
buo I'm I would eat all this chicken I
want y'all to know if you and move so
fast eat it all go ahead I'm going eat
while you ask you a question so for what
it's worth I think you have one of the
most underrated death scenes in the
history of media when you accidentally
blew your own head off with a shoulder
cannon in the Predator from an actor's
perspective what's it like to read a
scene about your own demise like do they
give you a heads up beforehand are you
left to just discover and process that
in real time reading the script for the
first time this chicken is so good
huh no you know sometimes on TV shows
like in season 3 or four whatnot a
producer has to come up to you and be
like hey man we need to let you know
that is going to happen hasn't happened
to me in a while but it's happened to me
before uh it's more shocking on TV I got
beheaded on
Supernatural uh I got squibbed up on
Third Watch I did lethal injection on
Boston Legal I'm black I died a lot on
camera before I made it to a certain
point right um but the cannon was fun
because everybody's like did he die like
what the hell just happened and I knew
because they wanted to sort of save it
if there was a too then maybe he could
have came back with like half of a face
deniability deniability so yeah that was
fun I dig
it mhm okay I feel a little bit I feel
my body is is starting to perspire a
little bit same with me we're in the
same boat here but you wear a jacket do
you do that to catch the
perspiration or what like I should I
have a jacket on am doing it wrong is
what I'm asking you know I think you're
doing it right I think sometimes I'm
just like you know I'm getting a jacket
off this one's hot but I feel like it
going in I feel like it I came to eat
this a free
meal you know what I'm saying go what's
up talk to me so as a former copywriter
for the Chicago tourism board I felt a
lot of secondhand pride in 2017 when you
did an explore St Louis campaign for
your hometown what makes Ted Drews
different from just like any other ice
cream stand oh
wow that's really cool and again kudos
to to everybody first time I've ever
been asked about the St Louis
advertising campaign in an interview
ever
this repping the hometown you repp in
the hometown um for me it's just ice
cream you know what I'm saying it's from
St Louis it is delicious but I'm sure
I've had others that are just as
delicious but if you come to St Louis
and you don't have Ted Drews then you
can't call yourself a proper St Louis
that's right should taste good besides
St Louis by Nelly is there a
quintessential St Louis song that should
be on any St Louis
playlist this is [__] weird
guys because I can feel like I'm
drunk like I like I feel it like that
that one it creeps yeah [__] creeps H
there's a song when I was in high school
this I can't remember the sister's name
with the song was s Lou and the chorus
went you go the S the T the L the O the
U the I the S St
Louis she this and that was the whole
song but that belong you got to put that
on the playlist you have to put that on
the playlist and everybody rocked the
[__] out of it yeah great how do you
think a dialect coach a Hollywood
dialect coach would unpackage or explain
the St Louis accent it's different
places have different regions cuz if
there like South St Louis white you say
things like farty like yeah we're going
to take Highway 4y and you're like you
can you not pronounce the word 40 no
like take Highway 4y far and people say
like oh that's got to wash up you know
real quick I'm like why you keep putting
RS and [__] that's not supposed to be
there then black
folks hair and here there all her like y
man I need to comb my her where y y
going over like it's it's the same sort
of thing so it's it's it's real specific
if you listen to any particular area
each one varies just a little bit but
within an hour you pick it up pretty
[Music]
fast mhm you can smell
heat okay it's getting real in the Whole
Food's parking lot it is over
here
oh
I'm okay going
in I know you done this 230 times dude
you [__] crazy bro I'm a crazy guy
I'm crazy over here insane Dar you're
red you're red you're changing in color
that just happened it's mind over matter
you're right is it my one of my
favorites is David
bla yeah D bla was so [__] cool bro
unflappable unshakable did he just like
blow out the back like did he go to the
bathroom well you know he moves sort of
mysterious you know what I mean so he's
just kind of in did anyone see him come
in then he was just kind of out like did
anyone see him leave like it was kind of
like that you
know but one of my favorite pieces of
memorabilia like from doing this show is
he gave me like the card for like that
trick that he did on where he took the
corner and I got that card signed by
David bla that's a good mantle pie
awesome piece man it was great though
I'm I'm I'm trying to do my best blame
what's happening right now I'm explain
it you know sometimes in adult
entertainment like the star tells you
what's happening as it's happening yeah
so it's like their way they talk you
through it I'm sort of sweating through
the
head I feel Misty in the T-Zone that's
what the makeup artist calls it through
here and here there's a little bit of
something happening
underneath the mouth is cool like the
lips haven't gotten hot yet cuz I'm
thinking I do a good job of trying to
wrap these joints around to
me
pause Ginger goat we got the ginger goat
man come on here we go Tropic star mango
lemongrass and stares hot sauce
yeah okay what you
got
yes yeah sorry feel drunk by the fifth
fighting the spice here in seven where
it's getting real [__] yes bro that's
just how it goes down this is the best
thing I've ever done in my life I'm so
happy okay so I read that one of the
things that Drew you to bias feere was
the fact that it was a very non- Randle
esque role of course referring to your
character and this is us for which
you've been awarded multiple emys sag
Golden Globe I'm curious at the end of a
six-year run like that with an iconic
character like Randall when you finish
it does it feel more like a relief or
more like a
funeral that's a really good
question it's both it's both because I
think as an actor variety is the spice
of life and there's a desire to bring
multiple facets of humanity to the
Forefront right it's also really cool
when people say like hey it's Sterling K
Brown versus he Randall I was like they
think they're saying something that's
really sweet and kind to what now was
like but that's not my name I'm Sterling
you know what I'm saying so when people
recognize you for a body of work it is
infinitely more satisfying than being
known for just one character even though
I love that
[Music]
character oh excuse
me
whoa
who
that might have been a
mistake you have a very shoot first ask
questions later approach you know
through this whole thing I told you I
already finished no redeeming qualities
really is the sense that I'm
getting oh boy taking yeah you about to
build my booty hole out
second oh boy the T-Zone it's not even a
T-Zone it's a whole face now is is it
I'm glistening yeah yeah you and I both
you know even though I'm not a big
sweater I'm going to woo
Jesus uh lips
side they're warm yeah they're toasty
and I start to get like uh like a
serious like Smoky kind of throat yeah
yeah yeah I can see I can hear it I hear
it coming up right now I have a bead of
bead dripping down the back of my neck
right
now okay it'll grow from there we got it
we got it okay so it's crazy I met you
at a Chargers game last week and I know
before you went to Stanford to study
drama that you're recruited to play
college football and you know you're a
fan of the sport through and through
from Rudy to Friday Night Lights Jerry
Maguire Remember the Titans even The
Longest Yard Any Given Sunday Brian song
overall what would you say is the
greatest Hollywood football movie of all
time
wow my
favorite man I love in Given Sunday
yeah I love Willie Beaman I love like I
love not only that but I love listening
to Jamie talk about like his experience
with LL after the movie well did you
hear about like those fights that they'd
have that's what I'm saying like LL
thought it was a real movie J like we
just acting over here man [__] was
really really fun I'm so hot Sean I know
I know I know well you know they say
that that like that scuffle that like
happens on field you know that that was
actually a real scuffle got into the
believe that listen like when that's
according to Bill Bellamy when you're in
that sort of performance and whatnot and
there's a lot of young men and you still
have a a
PR testosterone is still flowing through
your body you kind of trying to sort of
be who's the alpha yeah right like the
only time I see red now is if I'm on the
basketball court and somebody tries to
challenge me in a very particular way if
you want the smoke you can catch the
smoke I may have been raised by white
people on TV but you about to catch a
right now son I shouldn't have said that
like I'm saying things I see how you
guys do it it's it disarms this whole
thing it makes me say [__] that I'm not
cursed way more than I normally do in my
life I have to pay my kids like 50 bucks
out not supposed to do well you know
what we might run it up a little bit
more because we have a two few more
Wings To Go we got do and we going to
have to dab at the end there yeah you
already know you seen it come on what we
got is Dawson's Creek mhm how
wait it's
to Dawson's hot sauce zuu seven by H
go oh
[Music]
boy I want somebody to get a closeup on
CU I'm I'm doing work all right I'm
going go back and finish I see they're
moving it they're moving it I appreciate
that work what's up so I was amused to
hear a story about you sitting down with
your mother to watch your performance in
the FX show starved where you play a
crooked bulimic cop extorting delivery
drivers and restaurant workers for food
I'm curious if we were to ask your mom
what would she say is her proudest
performance of yours and then which one
would she say was the biggest labor of
love to watch oh God did she hate
stared she hated starved so much but I
think what she hated even more
was when my character had an affair on a
TV show called Army
Wives so she loved the
show she loved the show Army Wives and I
I played a psychiatrist who was married
to a konel in the Army so every week she
would call me and she'd be like I love
Roland so much because he's so patient
with his wife so then the week that I
blow this other chick's backside
out she doesn't
call she doesn't call me and she didn't
call me the next week and the week after
that because for the 3 weeks in a row
it'd be like previously on Army wise and
they just see me blowing this
sh and then one day I called M was like
Hey Ma you've been watching the show
like you having a good time she's like
yes I'm watching I don't know why they
have to keep showing all that
mess she was so pissed off it took her a
good six weeks to come back to that so
like Army W she rode like through
everything it was an emotional roller
coaster it was an emotional roller
coaster for her her favorite performance
of mine is probably not even on screen
is when I did a play called father comes
home from the wars Parts one two and
three she saw it here at the public
theater in New York City and she gave me
a standing ovation after it was over and
after she I came off stage and she saw
me she goes you're a real actor now and
I was like thanks Mom I appreciate it so
sweet I'm crying and it's not the wing
come on come on come on come
on last dab let's
go yep that's good A little dip
[Music]
action Cheers Cheers Big
Homie
M
unbelievable what a
performance get another pan
down all right how you doing I'm alive
if you're alive all right same way
together baby and you know what it's
been such a fascinating spice journey
through your acting career you know
going back to when you're doing
Kafkaesque operettas to keep the rent
alive in your Harlem walk up to now
lining your mantle with the most
prestigious Awards in acting but I know
deep down there is a stag man a
Shakespeare guy at heart so I'm curious
to close things out is there a soliloquy
or sonnet that comes to mind with your
brain and mouth slow roasting in hot
sauce boy I have a little more in ad
doubt there's something happening inside
my nose yeah where it's heat and and and
mucus there's a lot going on okay
there's a a sweet Sonet I can't remember
which number this is by by
Shakespeare it starts off
um when most I wink then do mine eyes
best see for all the days they view
things unrespected but but at night in
dreams I look on thee and Darkly bright
are bright and dark directed then thou
whose Shadow Shadows doth make bright
how would I say thy Shadows form form
happy show to the clear day with thy
much clear night when to unseeing eyes
thy shade shines so how would I say mine
eyes be blessed made by looking on thee
in the living day when in dead night thy
Fair imperfect shade through heavy sleep
on sightless eyeses doth stay all days
are nights to see till I see thee and
nights bright days when dreams do show
thee me Sterling K Brown you doth crush
the wings of death today and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
please pray for me when I go to the
bathroom later on today that everything
is is decent and in right in order uh if
you have AMC plus please check out
biosphere December 15th sometime in New
York and La there will be American
fiction uh my wife and I are going to do
a podcast coming on Valentine's Day uh
it's called we don't always agree and
besides that you can catch me at a a
football field in La watching my kids do
the thing that they love to do thanks
for having me Sean appreciate you
brother oh man Michael Geer I told
you I ain't drinking no milk son let the
record show let's go milk no
water let's
[Applause]
go you did so good
you did so good thank you brother I
appreciate that that was a bless you had
a good time I had a great time you guys
honestly you kudos to you for always
asking things that nobody ever ever asks
that's awesome W
Jesus hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans and T the season to
turn up the heat with our hot ones 10
pack that's right the hot ones 10 pack a
legendary lineup with two brand new
sauces book ending it on either side we
have the hot ones classic Buffalo as
well as the last dab experience made
with the new Guinness World Records
hottest chili pepper XX that's
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the Season 22 10
pack is the season to turn up the heat